well this morning we're exploring new
evidence that sleep deprivation can harm
your physical and mental health a study
from the University of California
Berkeley suggests missing out on sleep
makes us lonely and less socially
attractive
it also says people can pass on feelings
of loneliness to someone who was well
rested in just 60 seconds Mike Michael
Bruce is a clinical psychologist and
specialist in sleep medicine good
morning good morning much for bringing
this to our attention I know right why
can lose a sleep lead to loneliness so
think about it like this when you
haven't had a good night's rest it's not
like you want to run around to give
everybody a hug right so you're kind of
in your own space kind of being a little
bit more isolated because you're just
not feeling so great then what the study
found out which was pretty interesting
was you sent out this vibe like stay
away from me I'm not doing so well today
and that makes you even more isolated
and that the whole thing turns into a
circle almost viral talk about the
connection linking the two and the
research behind it so it's interesting
the study was done out of UC Berkeley by
Matt Walker great great researcher and
what he discovered was he had people
watching videos while their brain was
being monitored using an MRI and so
remember that Seinfeld episode with the
close talker you know the person who was
just so and it makes you so
uncomfortable so they used that kind of
idea of a video of people walking closer
to people and then there are certain
parts of your brain that will actually
kind of fire off and let you know hey
this could be a threat when you're
sleep-deprived that close talker could
be 30 feet away and you get that feeling
so okay Michael I got four hours and
eight minutes of sleep last night I keep
talking I don't work - Gael come on
hello my name is Gail I need help sleep
do you need to avoid feeling lonely and
isolated and am I making Gail nervous
yeah I'm not gonna talk about whether or
not you're making her nervous but Noel
or not sleep needs are different for
different age groups right and so when
we have kids like I've got two teenagers
they need between eight and ten hours
normal adults can you really kind of do
well with between seven and nine hours
as we get older that can change as well
but really remember your sleep need can
be individual some people might not need
exactly 8:00 exactly seven or exactly
nine how do we look
yes number is okay so there's a couple
of things that you can do first of all I
run an experiment with all of my
patients so we know the average sleep
cycle is 90 minutes long and the average
person has five of them seven and a half
hours you have a normal wakeup time of
6:30 your bedtime becomes 11 try it for
a week if you can wake up before your
alarm you found your sleep need if you
can't wake up before your alarm maybe
you should go to bed a little bit
earlier
maybe we contagious and we can pass it
on to you there you go
I like that trick thank you absolutely
absolutely there's a couple other things
people can do keep a consistent sleep
schedule it's gonna be a big one as well
all right unfortunate we got to go there
it's a problem you can see John say stop
talking